[Musik]
freunde der sonne nicht erreicht eine
ganz entzückende frage per mail ich lese
vor
hallo ich habe eine frage an schön
schlau ein kind meine hortgruppe sechs
bis zehnjährigen kids stellte mir eine
interessante frage wenn jemand so jacobs
frage in einem lift wäre der abreisen
würde könnte die personen verletzungen
vermeiden wenn sie kurz vor dem aufprall
hoch springen würde
andere kinder wandten ein dass man ja
nicht müsste weil man auf breiten das
hilft ihr auch durch seile gesichert
sein
ja so jakob aber wenn es den kinder erst
mal gar wie deine kitzen ganz schön
schlau denn erstens sind aufzüge
tatsächlich nicht nur durch mehrere
stahlseile sondern auch durch bremsen
gesichert zweitens haben sie ein großes
problem direkt erkannt nämlich wenn ich
nicht weiß zwar nicht auf pralle vor
soll ich denn wissen gar nicht springen
aber lassen wir das mal außen vor den
jakob möchte schließlich wissen was
theoretisch physikalisch möglich ist
nicht wahr jakob also im prinzip geht es
darum die härte des aufpralls zu
verringern die härte des aufpreis setzt
sich zusammen aus der eigenen körper
masse und der fallgeschwindigkeit die
man dann kurz vom aufprall hat die
fallgeschwindigkeit die hängt davon ab
wie lange wir fallen bzw aus welcher
höhe wir fallen machen wir es uns
einfach wir vernachlässigen jede reise
und gehen von einem freien fall aus
würde ich mit dem fahrstuhl von der
aussichtsplattform des berliner
fernsehturms abstürzen dann würden der
fahrstuhl ich mit einer geschwindigkeit
von fast 230 km h
ankommen mit 230 sachen im boden
gefahren wird dann aber selbst eine höhe
von nur zehn metern kommt man immerhin
auf eine geschwindigkeit von etwa 50 km
also immer noch gefährlich genug zweimal
mit 50 km/h gegen eine wand aber ohne
sicherheitsgurt oder er wäre einfach nur
in der kiste
also sagen wie ich würde jetzt just im
richtigen moment also eine halbe sekunde
vor aufprall hoch springen würde das
funktionieren der sprungkraft gehört
jetzt nicht zu meinen persönlichen
stärken aber selbst die sprung
geschwindigkeit von athleten kommt nicht
ran an die geschwindigkeiten von freien
fall möglicherweise könnte man die
aufprallgeschwindigkeit 5 km h
verringern mehr woche nicht darüber
hinaus befinden wir uns im freien fall
in schwerelosigkeit in schwerelosigkeit
ist nicht gleich die springen
normalerweise ist es ja so dass man
vorne springen in die knie geht dann
folgt seine gelenke und durch die
schwerkraft behält man aber kontakt mit
dem boden von dem man sich dann wieder
abdrücken kann nicht so wenn der boden
mit gefällt ingenieure vom empfehlen
dass man sich bei einem aufzug absturz
flach auf den rücken auf den boden legen
sollte damit man beim aufprall in den
pools auf eine möglichst große
körperfläche geteilt aber wie beim
abspringen ist es in schwerelosigkeit
geist so einfach sich auf den boden zu
legen wenn der boden mit dir fällt auch
nicht gerade viel zeit dafür denn selbst
ein sturz vom berliner fernsehturm würde
weniger als sieben sekunden dauern und
noch eine sache mit diesem flach
hinlegen einerseits ist die wirbelsäule
in einer günstigeren lager für den
aufprall wenn der körper waagerecht
liegt andererseits ist der schädel so
wahrscheinlich schneller macht
vielleicht würde ich dann doch lieber
stehen bleiben beide beiden höchsten
brechen mit der hoffnung auf dem
unversehrten kopf liebe sei es auch
wichtig das sind allerdings überlegungen
die wir uns in der praxis nicht wirklich
machen müssen denn die
wahrscheinlichkeit mit einem aufzug
abzustürzen ist kleiner als sechser im
lotto ansonsten ist treppensteigen
sowieso gesünder auch wenn da garantiert
mehr unfälle passieren schüttler
vielen dank an gabi und jakob und den
schlauen kinderhort aussehen wenn ihr
fragen habt schreibt sie wie immer in
die kommentare und wenn die lust hat
auch ein bisschen rum zu rechnen welche
geschwindigkeit nie aus welcher höhe
erreichen würde die formel steht in der
video beschreibung wir sehen uns
nächsten donnerstag und bis dahin
plötzlich